elie haddad président du rassemblement
pour le liban bonsoir à vous merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france vous avez certainement suivi la
visite
toute la journée des manuels macron à
beyrouth il a fait face à la colère des
libanais que retenez-vous de cette
visite
bonjour madame je retiens surtout
d'abord l'amitié propose de prendre
qu'aux libanaise qui a encore une fois
trouve qu'elle est et qu'elle est un des
incontournables qu'elle est là qu elle
est présente depuis des années on compte
sur la france
on a que je comptais le libanais pour
lui il apprend cette hausse et un autre
sur notre pays il voulait la france a
joué un rôle a pourtant un jour encore
aujourd'hui un rôle important c'est elle
qui a pris le leadership de cette action
pour sauver le liban celle qui comprend
le plus de libanais et le liban dans ce
contexte difficile que bien que le liban
c'est parfaitement normal naturel que la
france soit là et nous remercions le
président macro et toutes les communes
toutes les villes de caen qui ont
soutenu qu'ils soutiennent encore et qui
vont soutenir par la suite le liban dans
ce drame qui paraissent actuellement
mais savait que vu d'ici notamment sein
de la classe politique il ya quand même
des voix qui s'élèvent pour dénoncer
cette visite dénoncé une forme
d'ingérence de la part à des manières
macro et de la france au liban comme l'a
dit le président lui même c'est
intervention d'un ami il est là dit
humblement qu'il était le président de
la proche de koteba lieu de donner des
leçons de dire ce qui est à faire
mais comme un ami aussi hélas des
exigences tous on a des amis connaître
de temps en temps mais on leur dit il
faut faire ça il faut pas comme ça
comme conseil c'est dans ce cadre là que
je vois l'intervention du président
français
j'ai pas vu d'excès de
l'interventionnisme et de présent dans
la vie politique française peuvent
libanais aujourd'hui il a ils demandent
justement dirigeants libanais de prendre
leurs responsabilités
de mener des réformes ils souhaitent un
pacte politique est ce que c'est
possible au liban aujourd'hui avec la
complexité que l'on connaisse euros
niveau sur le champ politique et aussi
tout le contexte géopolitique
d'abord il faut dire que c'est la seule
voie de salut
il n'ya pas d'autre choix le système
actuel à me prouver qu'ils étaient
périmés inefficace au bar dangereux et
on l'a vu par morte elle aussi on l'a vu
avec cette action-là ce qui s'est passé
ce système corrompu qui a été instaurée
depuis les années 90 au liban avec le
confessionnalisme le clientélisme ne
peut plus continuer au liban il faut
qu'il y ait une nouvelle forme de
gestion du pays avec un pays moderne
laïque il ya beaucoup de choses les
libanais sont tous demandeurs de ce type
de deux pays mais le bie est bloqué par
quelques personnes pas quelques pas un
système qui est complètement désuet qui
gère la situation actuelle au liban
bloqué par quelques personnes par un
système voulzy qui particulièrement
écouté j'ai aussi fait des personnes
l'aideront les connais ceux qui sont là
depuis des années depuis 90 qui gère le
pays
c'est eux mêmes qui étaient les chefs de
guerre qui sont transformés en chefs de
bva le titre qui sont toujours les mêmes
d'ailleurs kiko contre le pays qui perd
oui le système tant sur le plan
politique ce plan économique que ce plan
à tous les niveaux même la justice me
met partout les banques le système celle
qui contrôle tout c'est eux et on
s'appelle d'énergie du pays depuis 90 et
continuer à le faire le liban ne peut
plus continuer comme ça il faut qu'ils
changent il faut qu'on passe à une
nouvelle nouveau pacte libanais pour
qu'on puisse penser voir dans les années
qui viennent va laissant les centres
années qui viennent et sur le rôle du
réseau là qui est jugée controversée
là aussi je jouais le plan macro le
hezbollah est un parti politique
libanais c'est une composante d'insultés
libanaise et ils ont personne ne peut
nier leur légitimité populaire libanaise
il faut discuter avec eux ils ont des
ministres et dont des députés
ils sont présents ils font ils ont sont
aussi responsables que les autres partis
politiques il faut 2 6 discuter avec eux
avec tout le monde d'ailleurs pas
qu'avec eux il ya d'autres encore plus
responsable aussi de l'aco
action de la station actuelle au liban
je suis pas là beaucoup dépend de qui
que ce soit une fille la peau que tout
le monde se mette d'accord pour bâtir
ensemble un nouveau pays un nouveau
niveau macro annoncé une conférence
internationale de soutien et d'appui au
liban il ya déjà une conférence on s'en
souvient quand je la conférence du cèdre
à paris qu'attendez-vous de cette
conférence est ce que c'est une annonce
qui fait écho au liban qui doit
participer le liban est actuellement
dévasté le liban était à feu et à sang
maintenant il est à genoux
malheureusement avec cette explosion qui
a dévasté tout le pays
vc c'est presque hiroshima à beyrouth
actuellement comme vous voyez sur les
photos actuellement tout est dévasté les
côtes est ruiné les hôpitaux sont prêts
à casser complètement cassé ils ont plus
de moyens
dire que d'argent déjà la dévaluation de
la monnaie avait avait avait avait tué
le pays et la société libanaise liban
n'en peut plus il a beaucoup de projets
mais il a plus les moyens de ses projets
les gens ne peuvent plus même
reconstruire la maison actuellement lui
même pu vivre dans toute aide est
indispensable donc autant organiser
c'est peut-être là au niveau
international qu'elle aille dans un même
sens et qu'elle puisse être utile pour
la société libanaise et qu'elle puisse
bâtir le liban qu'on souhaite sur de
bonnes bases pas uniquement au niveau
le liban n'a pas besoin de deux bêtes
matériel il a certainement dû doigt je
veux dire mais il vient pas quémander
l'aide matérielle mais il a besoin de
nouveaux de dunes d'un soutien
international olympique pour qu'ils
puissent passer vous savez ces
dirigeants qu'ils soient là on les
accuse tous de tous les torts mais tous
des agents du monde les connaissait
depuis 90 ils ont travaillé avec eux ils
nous ont ils savaient ce qu'il faisait
il savait où papé l'avant ils savent
maintenant encore où est ce qu'ils ont
détourné leur argent
il faut aider le liban à retrouver cet
argent détourné déjà ce sera un
excellent pas à faire pour aider le
liban
merci à vous allez à terre je rappelle
que vous êtes le président du
rassemblement pour le liban